welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and Rick and Morty season four
finale confirmed a longtime theory Morty
does we're Wranglers also Beth woods
cloned back in season three and the
writers actually gave a [__] about the
continuity this time thank God because
it resulted in this awesome episode with
a jerk depressing ending so you know
it's one we got to give the dr. Wong
treatment
Andrew explain Rick's sadness and bad
dad miss many of us worried after this
season strain episode that the returns
of Phoenix person and tani after the
post-credits scene from the season 3
premiere would forever be a non canon
hypothetical with no real impact on the
series this episode redeemed us and
we'll actually be chatting with the
voice of Tammy herself Cassie Steele
later this episode also all be breaking
down all the hidden animation details
and Easter eggs in a separate video
coming next on the channel this
episode's title is star Mort return to
the Jerry obviously a play on Star Wars
Return of the Jedi but Rick hates that
the second half of this episode turns
into a Star Wars type plot with a Death
Star super weapon and a Darth Vader
style former friend resurrected in an
homage to the Emperor's transformation
of anakin into vader but the big return
here is Beth who in last season's ABCs
of Beth episode what's given the
opportunity to leave her life behind
with a clone in her place but it was
left unclear whether or not that
actually happened until this episode
which confirms that Beth was cloned but
it leaves a mystery which Beth was the
clone for once in my life I want you to
decide dad do you want me to stay here
and be part of your life or do you want
me to leave
[Music]
big money eyes on the lady switcheroo
now the game pocket Morty's promo
suggested that space Beth was clone Beth
but you know it's the mobile game it
isn't exactly on the continuity train
with the rest of us you could make the
case for either of F being Rick's true
daughter a badass space hero in a war
with the Federation check or a
self-hating housewife who drowns herself
in wine do check like those are both
good daughters that you both want to
drop from a cliff but the writers here
have made it clear that we will never
know the truth that's turned around and
locked eyes with him instead tell me
what kind of daughter you would like me
to be rich response was to roofie her
and avoid the entire conversation which
is an ancient Greek level of bad
fatherhood and then you can't bear to
even know which one is rich it is I
think the most cowardly part of it all
you made a non choice and committed to
it really hard Rick has doomed himself
to uncertainty he stored this memory for
which was which in a mind-blower vial
from the Morty's mind-blower episode
meaning it must have been so upsetting
that he didn't want to live with it
constantly but even in that memory we
learned that Rick couldn't decide which
Beth to keep in which Beth to release
he's alienated from both would you think
about us probably because this Beth
wasn't even his original bit to begin
with he swapped into this reality in
season ones Rick pushed number 9 episode
ever all we know that's happened plenty
of times it's also worth noting that
Rick's stored this memory in a red
memory vial which we learned in that
season 3 episode is the color of an
anger associated memory Rick's angry and
himself for being such a [__] father
that he's okay living with a possibly
fraudulent copy of his real daughter he
doesn't have to think about it had he
simply just known for sure he could take
satisfaction in the fact that his free
daughter followed in his footsteps as a
badass intergalactic hero he could relax
and enjoy the certainty that Beth is her
father's daughter while they share beers
at Shoney's a restaurant that doesn't
serve beer last I checked but who knows
this could be another Shoney's
simulation by Rick like when he was in
Shoney's in the season 3 premiere but
Rick prefers to live in an uncertain
chaotic world because it enables him to
remain emotionally detached from
everyone so he mixes it up and he
alienate
both his possible daughters by making
them both feel devalued as possible
clones in their minds even worse he
anticipated this mix-up to come back to
haunt him he gave both his daughter and
the clone neck balm implants for the day
they would inevitably discover the truth
and come for him that's why this is a
red angry memory Beth even more than
Morty or summary or even of Rick's
associates was the protege Rick had the
most hope for and sure he could make a
case for Morty Morty certainly evolved
into a Rick figure but really Rick keeps
him around to neutralize his brainwave
signature and hide from capture it's
very much an exploitative relationship
there oh and by the way in the recent
vat of acid episode in one of those
alternate lives that Morty lived through
before living back to his safe point he
definitely visited that mind blowers
chamber so what a memory was he's
seeking I will probably never know but
it could have been the truth about his
mother's clone history whatever it is
when Rick condensed all the realities in
the Morty's mind arm Morty now lives
with that truth but unlike Morty Beth
Rick respects when Beth makes a rule for
Rick he follows it as we saw in last
week's children of mort's episode she
matches her father in innovation and ego
they make a pretty solid team that's
what makes this breakup so heartbreaking
it was Rick's last chance for a healthy
relationship I mean yeah he's trying to
reassemble his best friend bird person
which is what I'm calling him because I
agree Phoenix person is dumb but that
appears to be a no-go for now Rick stop
some stuff from going back into the
house because as we learned at the top
of the episode the garage is his man
cave where he could take refuge to avoid
things like therapy dr. Wong voiced
again by Susan Sarandon returns this
episode after accurately breaking Rick
down in The Pickwick episode you seemed
to alternate between viewing your own
mind as an unstoppable force and as an
inescapable curse but instead of
escaping his demons Rick locks himself
in the cave with his most fearsome demon
his own daughter a version of his
daughter that evolved to be even more
like him pockets full of gadgets to
counteract each of his gizmos which
included pokeballs it looked like Nasim
so in a way Rick did endure a form of
self therapy this episode that's what
led to his big realization Oh
I'm a terrible father the music that
plays over this break through through
the credits is the amazing
don't look back by kotomi and Rick and
Morty composer Ryan elder in a lyrics
reflect Rick's inner desire to try to
forget his shirking of being a loving
father
despite that cowardice hunting him and
haunting him forever Rick had one
daughter he could have had two daughters
now he's got none he's a mad sad bad dad
which is something we've always known
but hey gotta love this show for finding
40 new ways to prove it to us we're
actually gonna discuss this with Tammy
herself
Cassie Steele but first one of the best
things about the dungeon where I shoot
or explain is that I get food delivered
through this tiny porthole window and
that's where my good friends at post
mates come in when I want a burger or a
burrito or some other porthole shaped
food I just opened up my post mates app
and I love post mates more right now
because I can get food delivered without
even opening the door they created
non-contact deliveries so now when I
order from local restaurants everything
gets left right outside my door or right
outside the porthole they also have post
mates pickup which I've been using to
order takeout for my favorite local
restaurants definitely need our support
now more than ever I get to support my
favorite pad tight place and they get to
support my late-night noodle habit
imposed to me it doesn't just deliver
food they actually make my life easier
by picking up everything I need from
Walgreens or 7-eleven and dropping it
right outside my door
just download post mates on iOS or
Android find your favorites and get
anything you want delivered within the
hour and for a limited time post mate is
giving our viewers and listeners $100 of
free delivery credit for your first 7
days to start your free deliveries
download the app and use the code or
explained that's code or explained for
$100 of free delivery credit for your
first 7 days when you download the post
mates app anything you need anytime you
need it post made it and we're back
joining me to discuss this episode is
actress and voice of Tammy herself as
well as summers other friend Tricia and
number other voices on the show in a lot
of ways what I really AM is a deep-cover
agent for the Galactic Federation and
you guys are a group of wanted criminals
and
entire building is in a certain sense
surrounded you're saying different
summer I wanna oh really
Cassie steel thank you for joining us
Cassie yeah my pleasure my pleasure but
we gotta pay our respects to Tammy right
this is a great traffic return for Tammy
but she didn't last that long
she was raised from the dead at the end
yeah yeah in the most hilarious way be
really like angry zombie bird person
yeah I love that Jerry totally had I
[Laughter]
wanted to ask because Tammy began as
just like one of summers friends in
season one and she's evolved so much
over this series meet like a few
characters on Rick and Morty changed
that much but Tammy has like con this
full arc what has it been like to evolve
your performance of Tammy over the years
I mean gosh it's really different
because when I was first I guess the
first episode that I was in I was like
you know kind of like this like drunk
silly girl and I remember I went in and
it was like you know it was the first
season it was I think people hoped
people knew it was going to be big but I
mean I think it got so much bigger
you know after after everything aired
and like though it's just like became
like this huge thing but it there was
like you know it was just really like
fun and I remember I came in and I saw
Justin recording and he was drinking
beers - like burp when Mike is burping
I'm drinking beer and then at some point
they're just like all right so this is
Tammy in the background while you just
like go off and you know start you know
just doing whatever you do you know
just just just just talk about stuff
then I was like you know drinking my
beer and think I think I can't I can't
remember but I think I was talking about
like pegging and gangbang yeah of course
that's what they used yeah you know real
thoughts real thoughts that I've had but
you know I didn't I didn't think they'd
actually get out there but they did and
then the second season is when she came
out as you know Tammy the destroyer that
was just I mean that was really fun
because at first I was like you know
trying to play this ditzy high school
horny girl and which is very you know
came really naturally to me but then I
had to sort of like play this seriously
I go home oh I see oh I see oh oh I see
and it was fun it was fun to see her
transform and I loved at the end work
because I really feel like Tammy
inferred person or Phoenix person I feel
like their love is actually so real
there's like a beautiful tragic mistake
he wants to believe even I believe
they're like he's like crazy
star-crossed lovers oh for sure there's
like this there's a sad robot who still
loves like he's lost his humanity or his
bird person this but there's the soul is
still somewhere in the machine
yeah and I wouldn't ask Tammy got her
butt kicked this episode like she's lit
on fire her leg was broken did the
animators walk you through what would
happen we're able to see the storyboards
and like vocalizing
I read I read this script and when I was
in there you know they'll just do like a
in case I can't read they'll do you know
like a breakdown he's like all right now
you're gonna be set on fire I was really
impressed you know that I just came back
it's not like I was like oh you know I
was like burnt to a crisp
I got shot but I'm still standing I'm
still kicking but but you know a few
people survived that shot to the head
though how's that possible few people
get so but I just remember when I read
the episode just being so so excited for
such like an epic death and then even
when I die I'm still kind of like I'm
still kind of doing stuff you know
that's right yeah like my death because
you know some people you know when
actors are on screen and they have this
like they try and like prolong or like a
theater actor will prime for like this
is probably the best I ever had
that's a good point I I took a really
bad improv workshop one time when I was
in college and the whole point of the
improv exercise was if you ever get
killed in the scene make yourself the
biggest burden you can possibly be to
prolong your presence and I'm like is
this really helpful to an actor but the
exercise were like latch onto the
person's hip and like force them to
carry you around and don't let go and
like I feel like this is terrible like
this is that helpful yeah yeah it's no
but instead of yes and I believe was the
theme of it well I wanted to ask how
surprised were all of you to find out
that they were gonna be bringing back a
Tammie and Phoenix person at the
beginning of season three or we last saw
them at the begin of season three how
surprised were you to see them bring
them back at season four as well as the
other big callback this episode that
this whole Beth clone
theory from season three I mean I don't
know I just feel like I'm like never
I might never surprise really they're
just so creative I I wouldn't I just
everything I'm like oh this is happening
now it's kind of just like more of like
a huh
more than like oh they're so creative
animation you can really do anything
you're not like you know what I mean
it's not like it's not like this so far
for a while I think it's just like every
time I every time I see myself
I'm obviously more excited yeah I think
I I really love it coming back just
because like I said I feel like they're
like that star-crossed love well yeah
you know I was even surprised the first
time when you know when Phoenix person
came to be a you know because he breaks
up like the wedding and it's like and
but at the end she's just like no I must
recreate him I do love that it's one of
the few like romantic relationships on
the show that like you could actually
root for and I and I hope I hope even
now it still could survive into the
future in some way like no one's ever
really dead on this show right like
people can come back yeah there's all
kinds of respawning I one thing I was
digging into earlier this idea of Rick's
Rick feeling like a really bad father
which it kind of came it's like a quick
surprise at the end of the episode it
like the episode seemed like it was done
but I think the ironic thing is you know
I was thinking about this right before
we got on he's he's just saying like wow
I'm a really shitty father but I feel
like if I was I was really breaking him
down I think that was like you know I
feel like he didn't want to know who the
original was so he wouldn't like you
know love them
different they switch them mmm so I
thought that was really that was like I
thought that was really sweet
yeah I like that too and to me like
whether or not you think it makes Rick a
bad dad it's definitely true to his
character that he proudly prefers to
live in doubt and live in uncertainty
when it comes to relationships and
emotional connections like because if if
he can have certainty on any of that
stuff like the it's just an experiment
it's another invention as opposed to
like a real thing you know right yeah
but what one thing I love that I hope
stays true on the show is this idea that
there are two Beth's like we may have
two Beth Smith's that the the badass
space Beth and then the Beth we've been
living with do we think there's gonna be
like a regular thing now that there's
just like two moms on the show I hope
there was another me I would know
exactly what to do right and for all the
best and worst reasons yeah I know all
their weaknesses and everything they
want yeah there was a fun friendship
between them yeah you know Earth Beth
commented on how she was hot at one
point
yeah well it was like narcissistic and
like the funniest version of that you
know like yeah yeah of course they would
say that my favorite moment is still the
end though like after after because I
really felt like when he took the name
tags or the names off the things that it
was actually not even like an you didn't
want I feel like it was more like he
like I said like he didn't want to know
because he didn't want to treat them
different or whatever is that is that
but maybe he just didn't want to know so
the burden wouldn't be on him but I feel
like but then it's like you know there
are all these things like you know his
his loyalty to Marty and then
you know through the throughout the
entire thing and then also like he
revives like half of Phoenix person and
he's there and he's like yeah we should
you know what was what was the dying
words before he shot me in the head that
I thought was so funny yeah it's never
his like personal friendships that come
first it's always like his own pettiness
he had a go-to when he hates and he has
to do a Star Wars plot like and that he
always comes first and then and then he
always feel sad about the fact that he
has to put himself first which is you
know what makes this show great it's
always these episodes and with these sad
beautiful songs that we're always like
whoa what did we just watch this is it
was so great to hear your voice come
back in this finale episode Tami's such
a fun character so and hopefully in some
way they can respawn her in the future
because it's it's been great talking
with you and in the hearing you come up
on the show yeah I mean it's so much
doing it's so much fun doing the show so
I mean obviously it'd be fun but
definitely look out for my other
characters maybe they'll turn into some
maybe they'll turn into you know other
other secret identities absolutely if we
learn anything from Tammy no one
character is just simply a stock
anything they'll be serializable this is
a very economical writer screw he'll
find new uses for everyone well thank
you so much again Cassie this has been
such a pleasure to talk to you reminder
to all of our listeners and viewers you
can get early audio versions of show by
subscribing to or explained wherever you
get your podcast and you can follow new
rockstars and socials follow me on
instagram and twitter and you can
subscribe to this channel more Rick and
Morty breakdowns breakdown of all the
Easter eggs animation details be coming
up next on this channel and we'll close
out this week with our favorite joke
from the episode
made me go to a wedding and you killed
my best friend I should have said that
one first
[Music]